For over half a century,
we've searched for radio signals from extra terrestrial,
civil [inaudible], but it's been well
, a little quiet. Are they ignoring us or have aliens already made contact without us knowing it? The truth could be hiding in plain sight. How has technology helped us look for extra terrestrial life? Could bacteria
contain
secret alien messages and whatever aliens already live among us? This is what if, and here's what would happen if we've already made first contact with aliens since the 1960s scientists at SETI, the search for extraterrestrial intelligence have had their ears to the skies, listening for signals that could prove the existence of
extraterrestrial
life. Recently, bizarre and intermittent fast radio bursts were detected coming from a spiral galaxy like the Milky way, 500 million light years from earth. Some scientists wonder if these pulsating signatures from space are the result of
mini black holes or pulsars or even alien mega structures, but could the
signals actually be aliens trying to communicate with us scientists at Harvard
theorized that the energy needed to send a radio signal to a disengage.
Aloxi would require a planet twice.
The size of earth covered in energy collectors while
it is possible.
Scientists have found an easier way for aliens to talk to us.
And according to Robert Zubrin,
it could involve teeny tiny stellar light sales.
This idea has been gaining enough ground that the breakthrough Starshot
project is working on nano spacecraft someday.
They hope to beam them all the way to alpha Centauri while
tiny spacecraft could travel great distances.
Bacteria could potentially survive the journey as well.
This is because it's easy for a bacterium to duplicate itself.
And as micro organisms,
they are small enough to overcome the gravity of stars,
making it possible for them to travel interstellar distances.
Hypothetically,
a microbial could be beamed from earth and travel a distance
of one light year,
every 10,000 years in 50,000 years,
it could reach nearby stars,
but why would aliens be sending us bacteria?
Well, the answer is in DNA.
Just one gram of bacteria could be encoded with about
900 terabytes of DNA data.
Imagine a 200 page book.
Now imagine 2 billion of these books.
That's how much data. In fact,
micro biologists think that alien messages may already
exist hidden in DNA here on earth,
waiting to be decoded.
Researchers suggest these messages could be found by determining which
bacteria could survive the conditions of space. In fact,
some astrobiologists on the ISS have experimented to see
if all life on earth could have come from extra terrestrial microbes.
This theory known as panspermia suggests that microbes
may have hitched a ride on comments that crashed into earth.
So like maybe where the aliens.
Okay. Okay.
But are we really alone while microbial alien
messages could exist?
We're still not sure what these alien messengers might look like.
We're mostly familiar with terrestrial life where all living beings are made
from cells using molecular machinery with most life here on
earth being carbon-based. We might just be looking for the wrong kind of life.
Many biochemists suggest that Silicon based life forms could exist.
In fact, some scientists,
including British chemist in astronaut Helen Sharman,
suggest that aliens could exist in a place we cannot see or
study known as a shadow biosphere.
These invisible aliens could exist at a microscopic level
beyond our comprehension with recent UFO sightings being
declassified by the Pentagon.
Many people believe that aliens have already visited us
maybe in the not too distant future with the help of SETI
will finally prove we're not alone.
We're more on this tune into our,
what if disgust podcast this week we talked to Dr. Andrew Siemian
astrophysicist and director of the Berkeley SETI research center.
He'll join us for a deeper dive into the subject and update us on settees
progress in its comprehensive search for alien communication.